hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to would you rather now I'm
still continuing on the calm relaxed and
sexy kick here and I wanted to play
another round of this because I kind of
lumped these two games together and I
really enjoyed talking about these
subjects so I'm gonna continue on would
you rather be telekinetic or be
telepathic now this is the two
variations of being able to move things
with your mind allah star wars in the
force or being telepathic like dr.
Xavier and being able to read people's
minds now some people love these two
cars together but personally I think it
all depends on how strong the
telekinesis is because there's some
limitations in telekinesis and there's
some limitations until telepathy as well
but personally I think that being able
to move things with my mind if it's of a
sufficient power would be better than
being able to read people's minds
however if it's just like only able to
lift a pencil off the desk and make it
move like that's not really worth it in
my mind as opposed
keepers minds and no other thinking
because obviously don't collect these
creepy power didn't know exactly what
someone's thinking but it's also very
useful in social situation but
telekinesis if of a sufficient power but
also I'd really like to be able to know
what people are thinking most of the
time and that's actually pretty
important because it's a lot of things
that I can know about and there's a lot
of things that I could get it oh man I
gotta go with telekinesis oh that is a
tight split there it's just edging on
the telekinesis okay oh well the closet
would you rather be attacked by 50 duck
sized horses or be attacked by one
horse-sized duck now I thought it was
more like 20 duck sized horses but one
horse-sized duck god damn that would be
terrifying
have you seen ducks in action when
they're angry those Ducks are mean sons
of [ __ ] and I think that like 50 duck
sized horses would almost be too
adorable to ignore but that is a lot of
weight but I could still kick pretty
furiously but if there's one duck sized
horse I mean
maybe you don't know what I'm talking
about that's probably for the best
I shouldn't assume you know what I'm
talking about in that regard I think
I'll take the 50 downsize forces thank
you very much again
would you rather never eat pizza again
or never drink another soda see now I
already cut out soda from my life I
don't drink soda but if I never could
eat pizza again
I'd be rampaging in the streets I'd be
yelling at toddlers in their playgrounds
I'd be punching babies in the face I'd
be so angry that I would be arrested for
punching babies and yelling at toddlers
so I would rather not remember because
no one pad for you and number two he's
in his life would you rather be
spongebob or beep Patrick Oh
now see when I watch Spongebob
Squarepants I always identified I mean
yes he's stupid yes he's an idiot that
literally lives under a rock but
spongebob also has a lot of character
flaws I mean he's very positive person
but Patrick seems to get a lot of good
luck in his life so I'd rather be
blissfully ignorant than live as
spongebob because like it's serious when
I was watching the show I always
identified with Patrick or I love oh
come on everybody why am i the odd man
out here that's a bunch of baloney and
you know that Patrick is way better
would you rather be forced to walk
around for an entire month without pants
or shed all your hair for an entire
month
considering that I value my hair more
than my life and I actually enjoy the
panceliss lifestyle even though I'm
technically wearing pants this sounds
weird when I'm saying it's so soft and
sexy but no I'm taking off my pants
right now
oh so slowly sliding them down my hairy
legs my greasy sweaty hairy body sorry
my knee just jerked involuntarily at all
the grease that's
so anyway I'd go with the pantsless
state because frankly that sounds
amazing would you rather walk around the
mall naked or walk around school or
workplace naked
well considering both would probably be
a felony and I don't want to walk around
naked at a school because that sounds
just plain creepy I'll pick them all
even though that would probably be
equally creepy and both of these are
terrible options and both are gonna ruin
my life here we go let's go to the mall
naked would you rather dance like
Michael Jackson or sound like Freddie
Mercury ah sing like Freddie Mercury
there is not even question about them
even if it was sing like Michael Jackson
singer
would are easily be freddy mercury that
is so ridiculously stupid I can't
believe like Michael Jackson would you
rather eat fruit or eat vegetables well
this is a logical choice and I don't
want to have entire stick up my butt
about dieting anything health even
obviously I'd pick eat fruit I'm not a
prude
everyone loves fruit I mean yeah I did
it
vegetables are dirt for you but you
don't need to shove it in everyone's
faces
I would pick fruit wouldn't oh man oh
god I caught me off guard would you
rather have 17 testicles or the proven
testicle the size of a coconut well okay
all right so the first thing that I
think about having 17 testicles is that
they could get twisted up there is such
a thing as testicular torsion and when
that happens you lose a testicle so
imagine walking around with 17 tests
Ruth wick girls you don't understand
this at all guys who see this obviously
understand there's a problem there's
more than just do rolling around in
there and it's an odd number why is it
an odd number same and having one
testicle the size of a coconut would be
big and unwieldy and make life very
uncomfortable but at least you wouldn't
lose it
like that you know where is the scale
helping he regards I'm sorry I made
myself laugh that's not okay I'd rather
have the one testicle I'm assuming it
does the work of 17 so that's fine would
you rather have a house made of
sprawling underground rooms and tunnels
or have a small flying house assuming
that if it's flying I don't particularly
need if it flew over with new dreams
but if I have house-made a sprawling
underground runs and tunnels that sounds
awesome I could have my own personal
hunger games in my own house I could
lock people in and send them into the
tunnels be exactly like to massacre it
be
not as creepy as I'm trying to make it
but I'll take the underground would you
rather be able to survive any injury or
fall or be able to pull out any Acme
corporation product out of your pocket
so this is like these are both of Wiley
coyotes powers here on any Acme
corporation product but also the Acme
corporation is terrible and their
products never work properly if I
remember back to my it's not exactly the
most beautiful businesses actually it
only doesn't work when the people that
don't always win use them when like Bugs
Bunny is easy they work out fine with
the roadrunner I got to go with the Acme
corporation because that just opens up
too many doors I mean sure I be able to
survive any faller injury but if I have
anything in the entire Acme corporation
catalog that's an unlimited supply of
amazing oh wow oh come on people don't
know the value of the Acme corporation
would you rather fight three bulls at
the same time or fight ten bowls one at
a time either way I'm gonna die is this
really a question
I can't fight one bull one at the time
and when I cannot train for them what do
I have like fists what am I gonna punch
him to death
I hope they have one coconut sized
testicle so that I can slam them in hurt
I was gonna say slam them in their sperm
egg and I don't know why I hesitated
because it's exactly correct
but okay it just sounds wrong when I say
I want to slam a bull and a sperm bank
so I'm not gonna say that even but just
been a bring on the death just just
bring on the death death is coming no
matter what zipper would you rather have
to kill three of your neighbors pants or
kill one of your own good chica not Lego
not banana rim the who we have so many
pets in this house now I'm gonna assume
that my neighbor is very strange and has
pet cockroaches and that's all that I
have to kill some hey we're never with
pet cockroaches bye no nothing a purple
cockroaches and
would you rather snort ghost chili
juices or snort liquid nitrogen so what
they're trying to go for is a hot versus
cold thing but ghost chili juices would
not kill you it would suck like you
wouldn't believe but snorting licking
liquid nitrogen it would freeze your
brain not in the metaphorical like org
of brain freeze no it would literally
freeze your brain and you die this is
not a question Oh would you rather have
a child in seventh grade and raise it or
never have kids or adopt so I'm assuming
that means that I have the kid in
seventh grade not that wait okay I'm
okay I'm assuming that this means that
I'm in seventh grade and I have a kid
not that suddenly I have a seventh
grader and raise it because it actually
no that's a loophole in the way that
this is described I have a child in
seventh grade the child is in seventh
grade and I have to raise it that
doesn't seem so bad I get through all
the baby phases I don't even have to
worry about that I found a loophole I
did the win yeah he found the loop oh ha
ha ha ha ha would you rather be credited
with the invention of the wheel or be
credited
the invention of the Internet this isn't
even a question who gives a rat's ass
about who invented the wheel is the
first person that rolled a rock down a
hill who invented the internet now
that's more amazing way more impressive
than unga-bunga [ __ ] rocker oppa I
don't know why I worried like I was like
oh no that's offensive to cavemen wait a
minute this isn't it's not an insurance
commercial what am I worried about shut
up unga-bunga oh no would you rather be
Calvin or be Hobbes now this is an
interesting question and quite the door
and that's why I'm going off loaded on
you guys which one would you rather be
would you rather be the child that
imagines the tiger is real or be the
tiger that can be there for the job
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for listening to me as I quote
quiet calm and sexy even though most of
this wasn't exactly that but thank you I
don't know if I'm going to keep
continuing this but let me know if you
guys found a few occasional very cool
videos and I will get them done because
I play this just after the last one so I
don't know what you guys are sponsored
but I will be reading cards thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye I'm gonna open that door
something's evil behind that door okay
oh man I don't want to kill the kid